يدرك عبد القدير راهب دوست رئيس جامعه
اشنا احدى الجامعات الافغانيه الخاصه ان
مستقبل التعليم الخاص في البلاد على المحك
فالتحولات السياسيه وما نجم عنها من سيطره
حركه طالبان على الحكم تركت اثارها على
قطاع التعليم برمته وتحديدا الخاص منه وما
لم يتم استدراك الوضع الحالي فان نصف
الجامعات الخاصه قد تتوقف عن العمل العام
المقبل
عدد كبير من طلاب جامعه اشنو غادروا
الدراسه للاسف الشديد حيث كان من المتوقع
ان يصبح عدد منهم من الكوادر التعليميه
المتخصصه لكن البعض منهم لزم المنازل فيما
غادر الاخرون البلد الى الخارج
تحذير لا قصداه لدى اتحاد الجامعات
ومؤسسات التعليم العالي الخاصه الاتحاد
اجرى دراسه استقصائيه اوضحت ان معظم
الجامعات الخاصه تعاني ازمات ماليه وهناك
خمس وثلاثون جامعه خاصه لم تعد قادره على
الاستمرار في العمل جراء هذه الازمات
مع الاسف الشديد ومنذ اسابيع تم تسريح سته
الاف موظف من هذه الجامعات وقد تسبب هذا
القرار في اغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات
وانخفاض في وتيره الالتحاق بها وفقا
لمعلومات اتحاد الجامعات الخاصه فان هناك
140 جامعه خاصه ومؤسسه للتعليم العالي في
البلاد ونحو 130 الف طالبا وسبعين الف
طالبه كانوا يدرسون في هذه الجامعات
الخاصه بالاضافه الى توفر فرص عمل لحوالي
25 الف شخص
اذا لم تتعلم الفتيات والسيدات فان
مستقبلهن لن يكون افضل ولن يعيش المجتمع
حياه مناسبه وستنحصر عمليه العلم والتعليم
على الذكور فقط
نطالب النظام الحاكم بايجاد فرص للتعليم
ومن ثم فرص العمل وايجاد بيئه مناسبه
للشباب حتى يستطيعوا بناء مستقبل افضل لهم
زملائي لا يستطيعون دفع الرسوم الدراسيه
وذلك لضعف اقتصاد اسرهم اما بالنسبه لي
فانا لي اخا يعمل في الخارج وهو يقوم
بمساعده في سداد الرسوم الدراسيه
يرى مسؤول الجامعات الخاصه ان غياب المراه
الافغانيه عن الجامعات يتسبب في افلاس هذه
الجامعات ولتغلب على هذا الظرف الصعب فقد
اعفت السلطات في كابول الجامعات والمدارس
الخاصه لعام كامل من ضريبه الارباح بنسبه
اربعه نادر العرب لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبر امج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات